I feel like I was lucky in the people
that I got to meet but then I'll look at
you two and I think you've got to meet
so many more people you know you're
younger yeah yes you're going to meet
everybody I mean I uh I remember sitting
when I was 21 years old and uh I was
hired to write for the Smothers Brothers
I was very naive and now we're all at
dinner and Tom and Dick are having
telling stories about people and I'm
sitting there going
I have no stories I can't believe I
don't have a story right and I was 21 so
you've got to be this age 180 to have a
story you met General Grant oh my God
what a fun guy he was uh but I I do
think there was that whole you said Mary
Lincoln could be pushy
but no even uh you know just just in the
I mean there's that clip that I've seen
a million times I think it's uh you on
The Tonight Show with Johnny Carson
Marty and uh I think it's Betty Davis
sitting next to you yeah she was she had
already killed with her three episodes
or three segments yeah three seconds
yeah yeah everything yeah she did
that thing but you mean it she did Kill
she was she was great oh yeah she was
great yeah but I just think oh
Johnny Carson is the host of The Tonight
Show and sitting next to you is Betty
Davis that's an era of of Show Business
and I'd never met Johnny Carson so it
was particularly
because I loved Johnny Carson yeah yeah
as we all did yeah so much so that I
didn't even do his show for 10 years or
eight years or something when I could
have because I thought oh I'm too hip I
just do Letterman but the really I was
scared to well and people don't even
understand the era then because it's all
changed so much
but both of you have this experience
where you go on
you'd go on Johnny Carson's Tonight Show
and you do your your set and the next
day everybody had seen it yeah right and
um you know you could walk through a
hotel lobby and
um Steve would just drive from town from
hotel to hotel just to walk through the
lobby
wearing a shirt that said to just see me
on Carson and but people people uh I I
have so many stories that I've heard
from comedians where they were not
famous they did well on Carson and the
next day
everybody in the United States is saying
great job whereas today it's just my
observation of that is a little
different but it's too long and boring
but I'll tell you one no I'd love to
hear that okay well I've that's what I
believed you went on Carson and you then
the next day you were famous right but I
found with myself you went on Carson
next day nothing
then you go on Carson again
and the next day that somebody looks at
you like
did I meet you at a party in a long time
and then finally it slowly starts to
break through and finally on my fifth
appearance where I finally got it
together I did a good good shot and I
went into a store
on La Cienega Boulevard and the woman
said were you that boy that was on these
Tonight Show last night and I said yes I
am and she said uh
there's always that and I remember
seeing a clip Marty I could tell you're
just slightly different you killed but
you were just I could tell that you're
you're not the Marty that's going on my
show and you're just gonna kick the
out of me it's gonna be so much fun you
are you did a very funny thing about
spit take but it was I could tell like
his voice is a little different and
you're being you're you're being well
behaved you know what I mean with Carson
with Carson yeah yeah with you I don't
care
there's a difference between being
excited to be on Johnny Carson and then
to be slumming it you know
uh-huh there's certain people I've never
overcome my awe and Johnny Carson was
one of them that I always felt a little
you know I hope I'm pleasing him yeah
you know but they knew they had card
games yeah we played cards together we
had dinners that's a famous card game
people talk about that card game
it was really fun yeah you know and the
lesson of that card game is Everything
Changes I mean you're having what do you
mean well you're having poker games with
Neil Simon and Carl Reiner and Dan
milnick and you know Chevy and then
people die you know everything changes
I'm trying to bring up the party here no
no but it's and we're all gonna die too
no no yeah never all right well anyway
great scene so we're gonna roll on
credits
we just prayed right now
we just don't do a group prayer yeah I
think I'd be very nice and hold hands
yeah well I often think about
um that was it's it's almost my
the fact that I get to know you guys and
talk to you guys at all is always feels
like I'm linking to this very important
I don't know what I would say is I think
everybody has kind of a disdain for
their own era of Show Business and and
and
reveres you know well what we observe
and I I probably applies to you that
younger comedians like you know SNL guys
that we kind of know or if you know them
better than I because you're a warm
person
and but we see that camaraderie among
them yeah that we assume the you know
like Don Rickles had you know with Frank
and yeah but I see that we have
camaraderie with people of Our
Generation and I see we see the younger
people helping each other you know it's
a oh absolutely no I mean people like
Fred Armisen yeah and John Mulaney and
Bill Hader are all close close friends
you know
and you know them
no they they also have caller ID
I was talking to Fred Armisen once I
mean it's probably 10 years ago and he's
just hanging around SNL and he said the
latest thing that we this is probably
old now but right so the latest thing is
when you text someone uh and then the
misspellings come up and the different
words you just don't change them
and you just send it off like that but
you do that to other comedians Fred is
an interesting guy because I remember uh
I think we had it we were at dinner once
and might have been at my house and Fred
was there and didn't say he's
hilariously funny guy
but that night he didn't say anything he
didn't say a word and I remember him
looking up and down the table and
everybody's laughing and joking and he
was just observing it all and he has
that almost like you know I always heard
Peter Sellers at a party was not a was
very quiet and kind of just observing
and not I think we were all there we
were yes you were there it was a funny
guy's dinner it was a funny guy's dinner
there Steve I was yep yeah sure you said
funny guys you were a last minute
Edition I was the control group
Pauly Shore fell out